from reading your story I think you said
that the artists the late artist
formerly known as Prince yeah
gave you some advice and you had just
moved to Hollywood I guess then oh yeah
so I actually love telling this story so
I moved to Los Angeles before I got
accepted to film school and I just
figured if I don't get into USC or UCLA
if I you know go assistant director or
get a job at a production company over
the studios so I the second day I was in
LA I got an internship with a company
called propaganda films and on my second
day of the job a casting director says
hey um what's your name and I said Alex
she said Oh her name is Lisa fields and
she said um would you like to be a
stand-in for a famous rock star I'm like
well who is it and she said well I can't
tell you I said nah I don't want to be
stand-in because I want to be behind the
camera so I went back to my boss Steven
price and I said hey I'm Lisa fields
wants me to be a stand-in for a rock
star she won't tell me who it is and I
don't want to do it and he said why I
said because I want to be a director I
don't want to be in front of the camera
I want to be behind the camera he said
you have to do it you've never been on a
professional film set so I reached back
and she was on the phone ready to hire
somebody I said I'll do it I'll do it
she said okay so the next day I'm on the
set and the DP says okay Alex you can
leave now and I turn around and I'm face
to face with prints and I'm like I
really wasn't a big print spend at a
time but I was looking down at him and
our noses were like this far apart I'm
like wow she got forage heels on and I'm
taller than you and he's just laughed
and he goes can we have switched places
and I said sure so anyway we were told
not to talk to Prince I said do not talk
to him but he put talked to me and on
day six I got my letter of acceptance
from USC and my roommate got the letter
and she said I have something really
to give you I said okay woman Downton LA
and I'm on this music video shoot can
you bring it so she gave me the lighter
I opened it up and I went into the set
and I said I was really excited I said I
got a USC film school and everyone
started clapping and Prince said I'm
like glad because come here I'm like
well what did I do
so he said so you're going to be a
filmmaker I said yes he said let me hear
you say that I said say what he said let
me hear you say you're going to be a
filmmaker and I said I am going to be a
filmmaker and he said I want you to
listen closely there are four roles I
want to consider abiding by if you are
going to pursue filmmaking in this town
I said okay so he said first one always
he pointed up I always remember God the
Creator always remember God and your
Creator number two always remember where
you come from because when you forget
where you come from you die as an artist
and then number three was break the
rules if you follow the rules you're
going to be bowing and you're going to
fade fast and number four was always
give back you've must give back as an
artist and I said okay and he said
repeat repeat what I said and I did I
call these my four purple corner stones
remember God where you come from
um never forget where you come from I'm
sorry let me start over I will always
remember the four I call them my four
purple corner stones remember God in the
Creator never forget where you come from
break the rules and always always give
back and he said grace is really
important in your journey so after he
tested me on the floor
you know core principles he told me he
told Rosie gates his backup singer he
said Rosie pray for this brother that he
does not go down the dark path he needs
to stay on the path of light so Rosie
Gaines took my hands placed them on
princes piano and pray
made a prayer of protection that I
wouldn't be seduced by the dark side you
know well but Prince caught the fleshly
temptations and this is serious we are
praying for you and after she prayed
Prince said amen Wow and he said don't
forget when I told you I said I won't so
imagine that is a priceless encounter
that cannot be measured I just moved to
LA I just I finished my undergraduate
work at Santa Barbara for him to take
the time to tell me these things and
share with me his four core principles
and for him to ask his backup singer was
he gains to pray for me I never forget
this and one of the reasons why when I
decided to move forward with making FY
films a non-profit I rummaged in my mind
I remember Prince saying always get back
and he helped me I don't think I'd be
talking about my films if Princeton tell
me this about giving back because it
seems like all four things you've
incorporated the purple cornerstones
it's like that's all I tried to and in
the second part of the story and so when
Prince died right they did a tribute
concert for him and uh I called the
organizers and I said hi um my name is
Alex muñoz I'm Prince gave me some
really good advice back in the day I I
will do anything I will sweep the
streets I will sell popcorn I would saw
hot dogs or being uh sure I'll do
security
I just wanted in my own way pay tribute
to this great artist because he held he
gave me some advice that I'll never ever
forget
so they said we'll call you right back
and what happened was two hours later
they called back and they said we
googled you and you're a filmmaker why
don't you do a film celebrating Prince
and I said a lot of concerts ten days
away I can't possibly make a good enough
film and I said how about if I document
it so I went to document this Prince
reboot concert and the very first
interview I did is is happen to be in
the same exact spot when Prince told me
into
or purple cornerstones it was like oh my
god this is where prince told me to
remember God remember where you come
from break two bulls and always get back
and I felt really inspired like my body
was like trembling because I was you
could feel his presence in that area was
the concert breaths right in front of LA
City Hall which has rarely stopped a
video how uncanny is that then I went
out to the audience that interviewed
some people about the concert and Stevie
Wonder does this amazing rendition of
Purple Rain so I'm trying to get
backstage to interview Stevie and I
can't get to him and the guards are
saying you can't talk to Stevie he
doesn't want to be bothered so one of my
fi film alumni from Hawaii Adrienne
Kelly sees me and says hey um Alex what
are you doing here and I said oh I think
I told you when I talk fi films that
when I taught the film workshop that my
first experience on a film set was being
princess Tana he said yeah yeah but what
are you doing here I said I'm doing the
documentary he said well why do you look
at my hat I said because Stevie gave the
best performance and I want to interview
him and they won't let me get backstage
and he said oh I could help you
and I said Adrian that's really nice of
you but you can't help me he said Alex I
could help you he goes in the back comes
back he says come on he takes mini
Stevie Wonder Stevie Wonder's nephew oh
wow so I felt like it was full circle so
I mean I got like chicken skin right now
because Prince tells me the importance
of giving back I'm there to do a
documentary about this concert I can't
get to Stevie turns out one of my alumni
never told me he was Stevie Wonder's
nephew gets me backstage because I
believe I had access to Stevie and all
the princes backup singers and all the
princes backup dancers because if I
didn't teach that FOI film workshop in
Hawaii I would have met Adrian and then
two years later I see Adrian at this
concert mucus be backstage that's Karma
that is oh I'm doing what I'm supposed
to be doing and I told Adrian I said why
did you
tell me you were Stevie Wonder's nephew
you said I don't know you know me knows
I don't want people my family we don't
want people to like it's just cos
related to Stevie so we just but but you
earned it because you've come to our
birthday parties and our total I parties
and you never asked any questions and
you showed us love anyway so okay now
you know so I mean what about a blessing
right that oh my god what am I am Knight
is Stevie Wonder's nephew and little did
I know the two and a half years later I
would need him to complete my dog right
and you're in the same spot when you
first met Prince so this is a music
video back in the day yes is for an LA
City Hall yeah
so my dock is called um purple Datsuns
short just about how I moved to LA and
Prince gave me this advice and then how
you know 18 years later I'm doing this
documentary at his tribute concert and
how my first interviews in the same spot
where I met him and how turns out with
my alumni it's Stevie Wonder's nephew
and then I can do get the interviews
that need that's its own movie that's
the second part of it mm-hmm wow I have
a feeling like a lot of stuff like that
happens to you though is that that you
just have like this amazing
synchronicities or maybe I'm wrong I
don't know I just feel like you have a
lot of that that happens to you yeah I
think I um I
people often share this stuff with
people I put it on my blog and people
say why does all this magical stuff
happened to you I don't think anything I
don't think I see or witness magic more
than anybody else but I do pay attention
and I think I have a heightened sense of
awareness because where I grew up I had
to really be aware of what was going on
who's going to act out who's going to
become angry who is going to go hostile
and because of that I really pay
attention also writers and directors
have to have super sharp observational
skills so I just I pay attention but I
don't think I'm anyone special or I
don't have the creator's favor just that
I I do pay attention they always say
within
Wishon like we all have it I think some
people have it more developed even
though we all have that ability it just
right just from being super aware hyper
aware of surroundings and someone's mood
or what you know what will somebody be a
danger or whatever yeah Wow let's but I
don't even know how I never would have
imagined that one of my alumni would
help me make a better documentary film
and I was I met him because I was giving
back his prints told me yes asked me to
prints chose me to give back and I did
and as a result I have a better dog
about him right and then that person it
came full circle yeah that's a powerful
story yeah Wow
you